hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
or manga and today is a glorious day
because the very first episode of doctor
stone has finally hit us today I am here
to give you my first impressions but
before we jump right into it though just
some background on me with this series I
have read and am up to date with the
manga so my perspective on this is very
much based on how well it has been
adapted to it's aimed medium rather than
focusing on things like the core
concepts of the series but that said I
won't be going into any manga spoilers
not this time around anyway
because I feel like for the sake of
analyzing the first episode they're
pretty irrelevant actually so yeah
that's that and hopping straight into
the review I have to say that I came
away from this episode with a renewed
love for dr. Stein the manga is
beautiful and compelling but seeing and
animate it has really brought this world
to life for me one of the issues I have
with the manga is that the world itself
very rarely feels particularly alive to
me but throwing it into an animated
medium fixes all of that immediately
with wonderfully vibrant color and an
immersive atmosphere like when tied you
emerged into this world I felt like we'd
stepped into a place full of wonder and
discovery just waiting to be made which
is great because that's kind of the core
appeal of the series in fact I don't
know if many of you our civilization
players but this episode gave me a very
similar feeling as to when I start a new
game of sieve you're given absolutely
nothing and then you're charged with
homing a civilization through the
entirety of human history and Beyond and
that is a feeling I love because there's
just so much potential and even though I
know exactly what's going to happen next
I still feel that Wonder and keenness to
continue discovering which is a great
credit to the anime so this opening into
the series primarily focuses on senko
and tide you probably tied you more so
really and yeah there's a little bit of
user here but not enough to properly
judge your voice work but the other two
are perfect san'ko's voice actor suits
this role wonderfully he just exudes
that sort of innate intelligence without
coming off as wildly looking down upon
you and Taiji's voice actor has that
fantastic brute force energy to his
performance that really compliments and
coos calm nature as for the general
animation yeah it was pretty good I
don't think that it's anything wildly
special but I should say that animation
should not be mistaken with art the art
is phenomenal and I believe it's doing
boy cheese work a whole world of justice
I don't think there was a single shot
during this episode where I said to
myself that's a bit off which happens a
fair bit with me watching anime but not
here most times I was simply in or of
the beautifully crafted world and
characters especially the texture of all
the stirring people which to be fair was
also amazing in the manga I think the
anime has truly elevated this element
and I hope
the art stays this consistent in terms
of quality for the duration of the
season back to animation though I'm
worried that some people may take my
previous statement as negative but when
I say it's nothing special I just mean
that nothing hugely blew my mind the
best sequence of animation was without a
doubt the event and tied you being
turned into stone in particular it was
great wonderful work but it didn't make
me go whoa on the other hand there was
no animation that made me cringe either
dr. stone seems to have struck this
wonderful balance where I have no
complaints about animation whatsoever
and I love that because it makes it all
the more easy to just sit back and get
absorbed into the series Nanterre having
said all that there is an exception to
this the opening which we retreat to at
the end of the episode and it is a work
of art all on its own it is flawlessly
animated with incredibly detailed shapes
textures and colors voke this dimension
of endless possibilities the only thing
I'd say is and I guess this is
unavoidable but I think it's a shame
that they had to show you the extended
cast from the get-go I say this because
I remember when I first started reading
dr. stone I really enjoyed the period of
time not knowing if we were ever going
to see anyone else aside from our two
main cast members and the sense of
adventure that came with the gradual
discovery of these characters that are
all featured in the opening so people
starting dr. stone with the anime aren't
going to be able to have that because
they'll be expecting these mysterious
figures to show up one by one
rather than experiencing what it's like
to be thrown into the true unknown and
look it's probably not a major issue at
all because at heart dr. stone is about
the fantasticness of science rather than
hugely character driven plots and such
so in the end it probably doesn't matter
and in fact consider yourselves lucky
for glimpsing these future favorites
from the get-go now what I will say is
that if you came away from this episode
feeling somewhat underwhelmed and not
entirely on board with dr. stone I get
you I wasn't hugely convinced after
reading the first couple of chapters
myself I mean I did love the general
ideas presented but one of the problems
I encountered with the difficulties
warming to sanku as our protagonist
because with the shallow knowledge of
him he came across as a bit of a classic
arrogant genius not a complete dick but
a standard tropi character the likes of
which don't usually receive a lot of
depth and Shana manga and looking back
on those thoughts I feel like quite the
fool let me tell you I would like to
assure you that Senko is more than
capable of helming the series and it
becomes quite easy to identify with him
as things go forward not only that but I
imagine some people may have problems
with the first episode because apart
from the event of the entire world
turning into stone it's kind of slow
goings which is very much intentional
because we are starting this adventure
with literally nothing and the pacing
will reflect that but it's also
to rapidly pick up because you know
that's just what science does every new
discovery makes it infinitely easier to
live and paves the way for hundreds of
other discoveries and once you get
invested in that engine dr. stone pays
your readership or I guess viewership
off handsomely now of course being an
adaptation the anime is not a strict
one-to-one retelling of the manga it's
pretty damn close actually but there are
some minor curious differences for
example in the market I drew finds the
Statue of Tsukasa before he finds user
hero actually if I had to guess as to
why the anime decided to take this out
in place so a bit later I'd say it's
because it does act as a potential
distraction to the Wonder and whimsy of
the world and at this point we'd only
really explored three characters so
having this random stone dude moment in
at that point may not be the best for
the overall flow of the narrative so I
think the anime made a definite
improvement there although there was one
moment where I did feel the anime was a
bit lacking and warning this is a very
minor criticism incoming but it's going
to happen anyway and it's the moment
where tide you see sink whose work and
reveals his treehouse thing I'm not
going to show it here out of fear of
being flagged it in the manga the camera
angle on this shot was much more on the
grounds looking up rather than at a
juicehead height looking straight
forward and also the treehouse was much
much closer and it filled the entire
panel so it appeared to be quite a grand
creation what I don't like with this
shot in the anime is that by having it
so far away and looking at it from a
flat forward angle it very much
diminishes think whose work I make it
look incredibly small and on creative
it's like Tai Chi says sanku did you do
all this on your own and we cut to a
crappy tiny treehouse instead of a grand
survival palace and look once again I'm
aware this is a very minor nitpick but
that's what I do if I notice these
things they go into the video because
why not and interestingly enough there
was one little scene that was cut
entirely from the anime adaptation which
was probably for the best but in the
manga when everyone is being turned into
stone is actually a brief like three
panel moment of Donald Trump or a
legally distinct donald trump look-alike
in the white house being turned to stone
and he has a brief thought about whether
or not this could be the work of
terrorists and that he doesn't want to
die blah blah blah and i understand why
you'd want to take this out especially
in this political climate and personally
i think you should always keep politics
out of my fun science anime but i just
thought it would be interesting to point
out in conclusion i believe that the
first episode of doctor stone was a
resounding success it might not have the
oomph or the hook from other series
openers but the groundwork is there as
is the potential for greatness and i am
very much looking forward to the rest of
this series and if you are as well
let me know in the comments if dr. CERN
is something you might want to see me
review weekly because I'd be keen to do
it I just haven't quite made up my mind
about it yet but that pretty much does
it for my first impressions of dr. stone
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produce in general
then please do consider donating to the
new world review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style the please do leave this video
will like share or subscribe because it
also helps for this channel an
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan retakes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on dr. stern
this has been the new world review and
I'll see you next time